sauce estaba entrando en casa cuando
sintió un fuerte impacto sobre su cabeza
la bala vino desde el sur atravesó el
techo de metal él se inscripto aquí
el proyectil del ejército israelí es el
primero que alcanza los poblados de masa
feria está luego de que mayo el supremo
de israel lo ratificará zona de tiro
palestinos han vivido aquí por
generaciones pero como israel no lo
reconoce hoy no sólo enfrentan un
desalojo inminente sino que conviven con
ejercicios militares y el acoso de
judíos de asentamientos ilegales
aledaños
una vez los colonos vinieron en la noche
y prendieron fuego al heno también
quemaron los campos donde suelen pasar
nuestras ovejas que incluían unos 300
olivos y almendros o lobería
saud y su familia subsisten de lo que
cultivan y al reto de estar y la tierra
se suma que las autoridades les hayan
destrozado huertos incautado tanques de
agua
la administración civil israelí no me
deja atraer una excavadora así que usó
el pico para trabajar una pequeña parte
de tierra pero si no dejaran traer una
excavadora podría hacer más
en medio de esta grabación soldados
israelíes se acercan a la aldea suelen
imponer check points de entrada y salida
pero los residentes denuncian que esta
vez se trata de una intimidación algo
que preocupa a la isla sobre todo por
sus hijos
por dura que sea nuestra vida nos
conformamos pero israel debe dejarnos en
paz nos está sofocando andy una solíamos
vivir en cuevas ellos se oponen a que
vivamos en la superficie quieren que
sigamos bajo tierra
volver a la cueva fue la única opción
para ya ver que sufrió cinco veces la
demolición de su vivienda junto a siete
familiares se ve limitado por la energía
de las placas solares y las costosas
garrafas de gas es una cueva de una sola
entrada no tiene ventanas esto no es
vida y pueden entrar serpientes y
escorpiones la ocupación israelí quiere
que dejes tu tierra con la excusa de que
no tienes permiso para construir pero a
pesar de eso me quedaré en la cueva por
el resto de mi vida
como shout layline ya ver unos 1300
palestinos seguirán resistiendo en masa
feria está frente a la que podría ser la
mayor expulsión palestina desde 1967